i think we are now seeing the final days
of this
tragic and terrible episode going on at
the as of style uh steelworks um if you
think back um a week or so ago maybe 10
days ago uh beauty announced that um i
think you just reported again that um he
would seal it off so that not even a fly
could get in and out well that was an
indication that they were finding the
russians were finding it very difficult
to finally subdue the garrison there um
they've now come to the conclusion that
they've got to have some form of victory
to celebrate on monday and it would
appear that they've now resumed a direct
attack uh on the steel works in order to
try and snuff out the remaining part of
the resistance there so that they can
claim on monday that they have captured
mario paul and therefore they have
completed their land corridor from
crimea through the donbass into russia
proper i mean this is a tragedy that's
unfolding in front of our eyes some of
the civilians may get out over two or
three days ceasefire which is being
talked about but for the soldiers in
there i'm afraid the prospect is very
grim and i think we may also see the
very ugly sight of ukrainian prisoners
being paraded through moscow next monday
at their victory parade it happened with
the germans at the end of the second
world war i'm an awful feeling it's
going to happen again on monday
tell us about the significance of this
victory parade
well it is the traditional annual
victory parade marking the end of what
the russians would call the great
patriotic war the second world war when
a roundabout an unquantified figure of
around 20 million russians lost their
lives so they have every right to
celebrate that but of course
they don't have a right to have begun
this war they've got no right to
celebrate this war and therefore i think
we're going to be subjected to some
pretty ugly and awful pictures from
moscow on on monday um as we've said so
many times this attack on ukraine is
totally unnecessary it's disgraceful
it's horrendous and once again just well
done to the ukrainians led by president
zielenski for fighting back so hard
i wonder if you could talk to me
about the uh theater
in mariopol uh we knew last month that
fact in march uh that there had been a
direct hit on the theater where up to a
thousand women and children were
sheltering in the basement of the
theatre we're told that
children had been written in white
letters that could clearly be seen from
the sky in front of the building and yet
it took a direct hit the russians first
of all said it was the ukrainians that
had done it um it transpires
that something like 300 people
originally we were told had been killed
we're now being told that number could
have doubled is that a war crime
it most certainly is a war crime but it
and it's also
ugly characteristic of the way the
russians are conducting uh this war this
operation the special military
operations they're calling it um they
have learned early on in the war that if
they engage the ukrainians chin to chin
toe to toe the russians come off second
best so they've adopted this appalling
tactic of standing off and using
artillery and cruise missiles and many
of those in a very unguided fashion and
i think this is exactly what i did i
think i'm absolutely sure this is what
happened to the theater in mario poll um
an un an unguided weapon well let's be
charitable and say it was an ungodly
weapon because it was deliberate it
makes it even worse but it doesn't
really matter because the outcome of
probably 600 people losing their lives
is quite appalling and undoubtedly by
anybody's estimation this is a war crime
amongst a litany and chapter of other
war crimes the dossier which is being
prepared quite properly to be used at
some time in the future this attack on
the theater was really quite despicable
belarus um saying it's conducting
military drills um as a military man
what's your reading of that
well i don't know really i think um
the relationship between a lot of
belarusians and russia proper is um
somewhat ambivalent
um we've got good evidence that earlier
in the campaign if you remember the big
strike that came down from belarus
to achieve regime change in kiev was in
many ways um
interrupted uh and sabotaged by the
bella russian railway workers who didn't
agree with what the russians were doing
and the russians have based their
logistic plan uh on using the railways
down from belarus but found that they
couldn't hence they used road transport
hence we got this 30-40 kilometer a
tailback which became a huge target
array for for the ukrainians so i think
um president luchashenko's hold on power
in minsk is actually quite tenuous uh
and
those reports i think are propagandist
type reports i don't for a moment think
that russian forces will start to be
ordered by their president down into
ukraine i think this is um this is uh
this is a smoke screen and um typical
russian
anti-propaganda
so anything more that britain can do at
this time we know that uh the ukrainians
want boots on the ground that's not um
going to happen at least for now because
of the consequences if we tiered but
they also want more and more heavy
artillery
yes and their request is absolutely
right um as i suggested earlier uh the
russians have come to the conclusion
that if they take the close fight to the
ukrainians the russians will come off
second best and take huge casualties and
they can't afford more casualties
it's already come out in your program
this morning that over the ten years of
afghanistan the russians lost a lot of
soldiers but they've lost more than that
in the last three months so they are
resorting to artillery which means that
the ukrainians must do the same so
britain the west uh must supply and
indeed are supplying a larger quantities
of artillery pieces and ammunition to go
with it and particularly target
acquisition radars and drones so that
ukrainian artillerymen can pin back
russian artillery uh forces to um
we call counter battery fire to
reduce the pressure on their own front
line soldiers so this is very much
becoming an artillery battle and that's
actually really why the progress by the
russians in the donbass has been so slow
they're reluctant to close with the
enemy but they're much more willing to
shell from a distance and that's why the
ukrainians need all the artillery they
can get to make an effective counter
battery a counter-attack
we've spoken many times about how
i was going to say label but that's the
wrong word how we should describe what
is happening in ukraine and we've
touched on whether or not it is genocide
you i know are closely monitoring the
situation are you any closer to feeling
that it is
well the evidence is is mounting up um
the question really comes as to when
i say sufficient when the volume of war
crimes that can be um analyzed and
recorded is such that it's quite clear
that there is a wider malicious intent
from the very top behind it that when
that is proven then that actually makes
the case for for genocide um okay as
we've said before um back in the balkans
we thought in the mid 90s we would never
get the likes of milosevic and karadix
and maladic into a jail and try them on
charges of of genocide well they have
all been charged and gareth
are imprisoned whether we'll ever get
putin there whether he'll actually ever
live long enough that's another question
but other senior russians may well find
themselves facing an international court
or if not that then the court of history
i think will judge very harshly and i
think the case of genocide is looking
increasingly likely to be proven
and just returning finally and to a
topic we touched on during the course of
the interview 9th of may which is next
monday and whether in your opinion uh
president putin may take the opportunity
then to declare victory in the war in
ukraine and if so
then what happens does he pull his
troops out what happens
well
he may well declare victory because
frankly with his control over the state
media he can say what he likes and
tragically a large proportion of the
russian people will believe what he says
but the fact on the ground is that
there is no way that he has achieved a
victory if mario paul full falls which i
think it probably tragically sadly will
do then he can say that he has achieved
a land corridor from crimea through
donbass to russia
but that's as far that's as far as he
can go if he wants to be truthful about
it um
the sad reality
is that at some point
hopefully in the not too distant future
there will be some form of general
ceasefire
and the war will stop where it is and
where that will be
will be with the russians having
achieved this land corridor probably
having taken control of most of donetsk
and luhans province in the donbass
region and that's where the negotiating
will start but then you have to ask the
question
even if the court of world opinion says
the russians were wrong are they going
to leave
well i don't think they will they won't
leave of their own free accord and no
one's going to throw them out
nato and the west is not going to mount
a an iraq-style scale operation
to throw out the russians from ukraine
in the same way that saddam hussein was
thrown out of of kuwait that just isn't
going to happen so there may have to be
the realization of an awful new status
quo where 10 to 15 of ukraine is
occupied by russians and there's nothing
that can be done about it